I can pull up a quick demo go to the
induced platform you have it's just
empty screen with no workflows right now
I'm going to click on new workflow on
the top right and it just asks you you
can either design the whole work from
from scratch where you you know give
step-by-step input or you can use AI
assistance and I I'll go through what
that means but just ask for a workflow
name I'm going to put in employee time
sheet um and I'll run through what
workflow I'm making so I just put in
employee time sheet and then I'm going
to put in step by step this is just
English description of a workflow that I
want to design and for for context the
workflow is basically think of a
construction company or or a company
that has warehouses or physical centers
across the country and they have
employees coming in and filling in paper
time sheets um that is basically a log
of when they're coming into work how
many hours they're working what are the
breakes they're taking etc etc and this
company takes in all of these paper time
sheets puts them on an air table and
they have to manually calculate P rooll
for every employee because it's all on
paper so you have to take whatever is on
paper understand it then run it against
a company policy dog to calculate this
guy worked five hours this is the
deductions this is over time and then go
and enter whatever payroll you've
calculated back into an a table so this
was we did this for one of our early
pilot customers they have physical they
have a real back office of 15 people in
their Finance team that like finance and
Ops team that does this U but with kind
of in the new world with some of these
agents you can just describe this on our
platform crazy so it has hey identify
uh access the air table payroll navigate
to the employee payroll base from stored
variables identify a relevant employee
search for employee with the payment
status review time sheet data open the
employees time sheet Etc and then it
says calculate the payment access the
employment payout info sheet on Google
Docs using the time sheet data Note the
total hours work end time minus start
time deduct any breaks multiply the
hours work by the hourly rate mentioned
in the Google Doc to get the gross
amount d D any break time expenses or
other deductions and so this is the
step-by-step process that some human did
you're just describing it in essentially
plain English not code yeah and then you
just click create workflow what it'll do
with the AI assistance is unlike a lot
of
traditional tradition is a bad word to
use because it's all very new but unlike
a lot of other autonomous agents we
don't directly start running it based on
English and this is actually the first
time we are ever showing this product on
uh media like a podcast or video stream
but this is this is this weekend
startups exclusive thank you it takes in
whatever input you've given it compiles
it we have this middle layer in between
which is just the input that you've
given but structured into smaller steps
so it all of all of the steps that I
took in it just broken them down chunked
them in um so it's just basically access
a table then Loop through the entries
pick one entry just smaller smaller
chunks of whatever I described and the
reason this is useful is one for visib
ibility for who's designing this
workflow they can see whatever input
they what's the final translation um and
then what what you can also have
visibility into is we split it into a
bunch of different action types so it's
you know going to the web page is one
action clicking filling all of those are
standard web actions um then there's a
bunch of data actions like looping you
know identifying filtering that that you
can do on the page and then we have the
agent blocks which are all of the smart
actions so once you go to an employees
time sheet any calculation that you want
to do you can use the agent block to
delegate and get inputs from model so
it's it's basically a bunch of different
block types depending on what your
workflow step is that we automatically
identify and put in you you can
obviously edit you can obviously make
changes to this and at the end you can
have standard you know El or outputs in
whatever format so after the workflow is
run you know you can have triggers that
give you API call put it in a Google
sheet or anything that you need so it
just puts an in into these formats and
if you notice for those that can see the
screen um it automatically puts in these
variables um across the step so if if if
your workflow involves capturing data
from one place and then using it in
another step later on it's basically
I'll talk more about the browser
environment but this is basically a
runtime that is designed for agent so it
has access to its own file system its
own memory um it can store data retrieve
data basically it's basically firing up
a computer in the cloud essentially or a
browser session I don't know if you're
using Chrome or Chrome OS or Windows you
can like up a virtual browser or a v
virtual machine anywhere AWS Etc so
you're basically popping up a desktop
and then running the stuff yeah yeah so
we we spin up a chromium Fork on the
cloud so it's a virtual machine with a
chromium Fork it's it's a custom browser
that we've designed specifically for
running Bots and autonomous agents and
systems like that which you can go into
but that that's kind of it spins that up
which is why it has access to all of
these tools that you can use in the
floow and then once you is happy with
the workflow just click run this is kind
of interesting because the way it runs
is it spin the browser that is spun up
on the cloud you can see a real-time
live stream of the browser when the
workflow is running so it's as if you're
watching and a team member screen you
can see the stuff that's happening on
the remote browser stream livey on the
left and on the right you can see step
by step what's being done um so you can
see the stream goes to a table it Loops
through the entries it picks one of the
employees um opens the employees data
opens up this time sheet and then now
it's going to run OCR and it can use
tools on its own as long as you're
giving it step descriptions so use OCR
document processing to capture text
input from this document store it in
memory then it'll go to this Google doc
which has information about how you
calculate payroll based on the time
sheet data it'll capture this in memory
as well and then once it has both of
these things in memory it's going to
compare both the data points run a
reasoning step which is why reasoning
steps usually take longer but it's going
to take both of those things in
calculate a final payroll amount and you
can see the variables being referenced
here um we'll go back to air
table and it's just going to fill in
we've got a bunch of fields that were to
be calculated just going to come back
fill in total hours work is nine big
duration is one over time is zero total
payable Li to
seven you'll put in the hours you'll put
in total amount and and the interesting
thing is because this is all running
remotely uh we can we kind of call this
the mission control view of um the
platform where you can have a bunch of
different browser instances doing
different things or the same thing
running at the same time so it's like a
real back office you can scale up scale
down you can have 50 instances running
at once you can have five we've got one
that's we've got the air table instance
we've got one running LinkedIn we've got
one on AWS a tech crunch thing here and
you can kind of see live streams of all
of them so for the the task of of a
manager who's managing a 15 member back
office team goes from actually
delegating tasks to real people to just
sitting and watching you 15 of these
screens and C if something goes wrong
just go in and flag it but otherwise you
can have a top level view of everything
so if I'm running some insurance company
sales team customer support whatever my
startup has these six or 15 agents
running doing the tasks that humans were
previously done and you just watch them
and make sure it's doing it correct and
it feels like you've been working on
this for less than a year how many
months into this are you um we started
working on this around April of this
year so March April is when we started
so you're six months into this process
yes um and we've we've kind of
identified so just just as a as a
disclaimer for this this run was very
well described so I I gave you know
explicit input I described everything
and that's how it run it it doesn't
require me to manually skip the whole
thing and it runs reliably once I've
given input but it requires explicit
input and I think we we took that uh the
the approach that we've taken
architecturally which I was talking
about uh was was is like the most
important thing in this six-month
process that I think has helped us a lot
where instead of designing an automation
product that sits as a Chrome extension
and then you use it synchronously on
your computer where I have an extension
I record something and then I can
replicate or I have an extension that is
an assistant and I give it commands on
my Chrome and it's doing things we
design everything to be remote and have
it on environment so we took we took
chromium fed it made made some changes
to it how the Dom comes out how the HTML
comes out has anybody started using this
yet in like a real world situation or
are you still in the laboratory we we
launched early October and we went live
with a couple of folks we are live with
about 15 uh now and that is across
different sizes small companies midsize
companies we've kind of found our sweet
spot in these mid mid- Market to Mid to
up Market companies that are operating
in sort of older Industries like
healthcare um you know Financial
Services
Etc starting a business used to be such
a painful process you needed to get a
lawyer there were tons of fees it was a
mess but not anymore
just check out Northwest registered
agent they're going to help you form
your company fast remember speed matters
and then they're going to get you the
docks you need to open a business bank
account instantly then they're going to
provide you with mail scanning and a
business address and they're going to do
all that keeping your personal privacy
intact Northwest can form llc's
corporations and nonprofits and here's
why Founders love Northwest there's no
hidden fees there's no upselling you can
call them or cancel at any time and
Northwest has the best of both worlds
solution it's simple and self served but
they can be Hands-On if you need help
with their amazing registered agent
service Northwest provides everything
you need to start and maintain your
business and they're giving twist
listeners a 60% discount for just $39
plus State fees they'll form your LLC
Corporation or nonprofit so visit
northwestregisteredagent
docomo northwestregisteredagent